kamme joins the party to talk about
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 n snack
snack snack exactly I mean we've all
seen Chris Pratt posting these hilarious
videos playing what's my snack well a
special challenge for Chris to test his
snack sniffer wearing the most
ridiculous blind words you've ever seen
in your life check it out
that's awesome those are your eyes on
the outside this is the truth
our first knock challenge some tasty
salmon the plate you just lift it up
have a little sniff it's like a pasta
dish with some kind like macaroni and
cheese with garlic on top over one it's
salmon score fault I do have a cold that
could've done worse
next we tested Chris's sweet tooth with
a lemon choc it's a dessert yeah yeah a
little piece of chocolate cake or
something woman it's Lymon yes it is
it's a lemon tart there it is you know
believe me you can watch lemon finally
some stinky cheese that's cheese oh
there you go yeah you got cheese ketchup
that's some real strong you like blue
cheese
yes chris is such a gamer he endured a
tough diet and fitness regimen for his
role as star-lord and guardians of the
galaxy ball you to dehydration sure
cutting out carbohydrates doing a series
of salt baths Wow
spray tan do it listen man listen you
got to do it what about like push-ups
before the scene I will go show to knock
over so do push-ups pull-ups you know
the main thing you need to lose shame
you have to not be afraid to be like yes
I am the douche doing curls just perform
a scene Chris's dad in the film is
played by movie legend Kirk Russell did
you count a fanboy out on him a little
bit yes
yeah I think so I think we move right
past that almost immediately and go into
the things that you know we're both
outdoors men we you know like to fish
and hunt and also both big family guys
and yes yeah was Goldie around - yeah he
married he married like a superhot
blonde median you know
hey wait a minute let me say this there
were moments talking to Chris hood I
could not even speak I was laughing so
hard love that guy